en este vídeo vamos a aumentar nuestra
intuición para multiplicar decimales
supongamos que queremos multiplicar 8
por 7 décimas pausa en el vídeo y vean
si lo pueden resolver por su cuenta
bueno existen varias formas de
multiplicar 8 por 7 décimas que podemos
usar por ejemplo esto lo podemos ver
como ocho veces y después podemos
escribir siete décimas como fracción así
que podemos reescribirlo como siete
decimos 7 sobre 10 que es lo mismo que
0.7 y nosotros ya sabemos cómo
multiplicar fracciones 8 es lo mismo que
8 entre 18 enteros y eso por 7 sobre 10
por 7 décimos y esto es igual a si
multiplicamos el numerador nos queda 56
y si multiplicamos los denominadores
tenemos 10 y eso tiene mucho sentido
porque si tenemos 8 por 7 decimos
el resultado es 56 decimos
ahora también podemos escribir 56
décimos como 56 entre 10 que es lo mismo
que si escribimos 50 entre 10 más 6
entre 10 así que esto es igual a 50 y 25
enteros y seis décimos y esto lo podemos
escribir como cinco y seis décimas 5.6
siempre es bueno verificar cuando tengan
un resultado después de multiplicar
decimales
vamos a ver siete décimas es un poco
menos que 1 así que al multiplicar ocho
veces por algo que es un poco menos que
uno esperaríamos que el producto sea
menor a ocho por lo que 5.6 tiene
sentido pero si por alguna razón al
hacer esta operación hubiéramos obtenido
60 podrían decir que eso no tiene
sentido porque debemos de obtener un
valor menor a 8 e igualmente si de
alguna manera se tuviera un resultado
parecido a 1
bueno eso es mucho menos que 8 debe de
salir algo que es siete décimos de ocho
bien otra forma de resolverlo es si
escribimos ocho por y ahora escribiré
esto un poco diferente lo voy a escribir
como 8 por 7 decimos entonces si tenemos
8 por 7 esto a que es igual bueno 8 por
7 56 así que esto es igual a 56 décimas
y 56 décimas es lo mismo que 50 décimas
+ 6 décimas
pero 56 décimas es lo mismo que 50 euros
entonces tenemos 50 euros y 6 décimas
que es exactamente lo que tenemos aquí
cinco enteros y seis décimas hagamos
otro ejemplo supongamos que ahora
queremos saber cuánto estrés por 0.87
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
bueno nuevamente hay diferentes maneras
de resolverlo pero podemos empezar con
la misma forma que acabamos de ver
podemos decir que esto es igual a 3 x y
vamos a reescribir esto porque lo
podemos representar como 87 centésimas
87 centésimas cuánto nos queda si
multiplicamos 3 por 87 bueno esto será
igual a una cierta cantidad de
centésimas pero para saber a cuántas
primero necesitamos saber cuánto estrés
por 87 entonces 7 por 3 es 21 ahora
tenemos dos
y después 8 por 3 es 24 que en realidad
son 24 decenas entonces 24 decenas más
dos decenas nos dan 26 decenas que es lo
mismo que 260 decenas así que nos queda
261 por lo tanto 3 por 87 de algo es
igual a 261 de s algo que en este caso
son centésimas así que tenemos 200 61
centésimas pero como podemos expresar
esto en decimal
bueno hay un par de formas en las que lo
podemos resolver vamos a pensar en que
esta es la posición de las unidades esta
es la posición de las décimas y esta es
la posición de las centésimas entonces
claramente tenemos una centésima tenemos
un 1 en la posición de las centésimas y
si tenemos 60 centésimas 60 centésimas
es lo mismo que seis décimas y
finalmente si tenemos 200 centésimas
y que dos enteros otra forma de hacerlo
es empezando en la posición de las
centésimas y llenar las posiciones desde
ahí como lo que quieres escribir es 261
escribes 160 centésimas y después 200
centésimas y así te queda 2.61 pero otra
forma en la que podrías hacerlo sería
como lo vimos en el ejemplo anterior
esto es lo mismo que 3 por 87 centésimos
todo esto es equivalente pero espero que
alguna o varias de estas formas te
ayuden a entender lo que estamos
haciendo y bueno esto es lo mismo que
tres enteros por 87 centésimos esto es
igual a vamos a ver en el numerador
tenemos 3 por 87 y en el denominador 1
por 100 es igual a 100 y ya sabemos que
3 por 87 es igual a 261 entonces nos
quedan 261 centésimos como pueden ver el
100 cabe dos veces en 261 y nos
quedan 61 centésimas así que todas estas
son representaciones equivalentes y
recuerden que siempre es bueno revisar
por ejemplo aquí tenemos tres veces de
algo que es menor a 1 así que
esperaríamos obtener un valor que es
ligeramente menor a 3 y 2.61 concuerda
con eso pero si por alguna razón
obtuvieron 26 261 les falta algo
incluso si obtuvieron 0.2 161 algo no
está bien espero que les haya servido